the more burgers the more better burger
show approved
wow
[Music]
like many things affected by kova 19 the
past year and a half has been grim for
the restaurant industry
but in the wake of the pandemic's
destruction a beautiful thing happened
a vibrant pop-up movement took root in
los angeles it's no exaggeration to say
that this is a burger revolution thanks
to an explosion of underground hamburger
sands that have poured their heart out
for the city we love so much
today i'm meeting up with some good
friends of mine to celebrate two special
backyard pop-ups
first we're gonna hit yellow paper to
try their classic double cheeseburger
with chef's knuckle and arjun from
bodmash and burgers 99.
after that i'm going to link up with the
homie dj so super sam
to try an epic smash burger from hangars
this one goes out to the city i love
[Music]
where the [ __ ] are we bro we're here for
burgers bro i need big comfort right now
i mean if it's popping we're gonna pull
up that's it even if we got to pull up
in a [ __ ] alley
we're in the middle yeah we out here so
i'm taking you all to one of the best
burger pop-ups in all of lake
got hot during the pandemic yo they
don't even do this no more bro they've
blown up
they're beyond the backyard now this is
the og spot
burgers are for the people man my most
beautiful memories of having a burger
are in a backyard
so this is really special you know we've
been hit hard with coven
we've lost a bunch of restaurants rest
in peace
and what's dope about los angeles is
that we're a community bro we come and
we support
yeah cheers cheers yellow paper
let's run it let's run it
my name is colin my name is katie and
together we
run yellow paper burger we're basically
operating a burger drive through
out of our backyard i was a bartender at
tony's saloon
on sundays we would make burgers set up
in the parking lot
and then serve people on the patio last
year july i got laid off
and katie was still working yeah i was
working at tartine doing pastry we were
just like
should we try to do a pop-up out of our
backyard should we just make burgers and
like see if people will
come a lot of my favorite burgers
especially in la are wrapped in yellow
paper
little one-off spots and like hole in
the wall and that's where the name comes
from
yellow paper burger so it's like a
classic
california cheeseburger it's smash but
it's not super
thin lacy edge we just season it with
salt and pepper american cheese
chopped chilies lettuce tomato onions
pickles the bun
is small it's white and squishy it's
just very simple and classic
i started making hand pies because i
love them i love making pie dough
they're amazing you know cheeseburgers
and apple pie like what's more
classic american food than that
it's a bit of an adventure too like you
have to place an order you
then you find out the address then you
got to figure out how to get there you
would pull up an alley like what is this
sketchy alley
but then we come out and give you your
burger you know and you're like [ __ ]
yeah this is
awesome
i'm never more in my element than i am
right now
i'm not even lying to you we're in the
backyard burgers i'm with my best
friends in the whole world we got the
styrofoam cups
bags we have colin and katie and i love
this
how it's just written on yellow paper
with a marker my favorite part is
there's no [ __ ] menu it's just like
yo
you're gonna eat what we serve you and
that's it show us how you do things yeah
i'm ready man yeah i'm ready
we just do singles and doubles but we're
gonna make doubles for you guys
all day but what's the ratio like you
[ __ ] with the single or you like the
double cause like meet the bun
it's it's a big deal i kind of like two
singles like back to back that's what
i'm saying i'm a single boy
butter on the buns on the griddle and
then you're also getting that
residual grease you know it's dad's
favorite [ __ ] gadget
the butter wheel i call it
you got the what i call the dowel method
which is a
cocktail muddler from the bar yeah very
important
mayo on the top and the bottom
if you don't have mayo on your burger
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't [ __ ]
want it
of course american cheese chopped
chilies right on the cheese
then onions pickles tomato lettuce
this is key oh shredded lettuce
oh she has a tuck-and-roll move she's a
baker she ain't playing she's [ __ ]
detailed to like no limit
we're not just eating burgers we have
the
world famous handpies and thank you
there you guys go yellow paper it's time
to eat
yes please i mean look at how [ __ ]
beautiful this burger is bro
yeah oh very nice
the seasoning spot off yo
the bottom bun is becoming translucent
yeah as we eat
it's just sucking everything up that's
perfect nothing's popping out
the construction of a burger is like
super super important like people don't
[ __ ] understand yeah like they just
put lettuce underneath the meat
the composition is very key like that's
the difference between like a fast food
burger and a burger that's like made
with
knowledge and love with you in mind
number one thing
is the product i mean there's a lot of
people that believe in like
if you have a cool hat or a celebrity
following you on instagram
if the product isn't good you're not
popping and this shit's slapped
so that's a good rule i don't even know
i gotta see this what's this pie
saying though i feel like this is like
when
everyone met up in staten island formed
a group called wu-tang
i had that raw energy just
radiating in the middle of monterey park
east
la off to 60 freeway right now you gotta
make something this is definitely
something
oh [ __ ] yeah the pie is [ __ ] crazy
that pie is nuts remember what we used
to say before about community over
competition remember knuckle that was
like words from you
yeah there's a [ __ ] ton of burger pops
there's like 12 year old kids like
popping up and be like yo
i'm the next george remotes i'm smashing
burgers with onions in it and [ __ ] if
you're trying to make a burger in your
backyard
do it how far do you want to take it i
hope they
take it to the next level because i feel
like more people
should eat this yeah agreed once the
state gets opened up 100 again
it's gonna be the wild wild west of
burgers in los angeles [ __ ] hide your
kids man
yeah it's serious for real the more
burgers the more better right
yeah coming back to coven it's push
people to go
simple you don't see pop-ups selling for
raw burgers exactly
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i love this it's kind of
like a reset
it's just a burger right yeah but you
said homie has technique
yellow paper burger the best
for real arjun knuckle
thanks for joining me thank you for
having us i have to run to the next spot
i gotta go grab another burger in the
beautiful city that i love you live a
tough life y'all
live a tough life burger show baby we
out
shout out the [ __ ] album the dawn
hey hi alvin
i'm so excited i am too where are we el
cerino
el cerino yes we're on the east side
we're in one of the oldest neighborhoods
of los
angeles the streets have been talking
and they're saying that this is the spot
to be
i'm so excited eating burgers during the
pandemic i have been eating burgers
during the pandemic but mostly
you're gonna be so mad at it why i
yeah [ __ ] monty's huh not monty which
one
no i'm not even gonna say no no this is
this is because
it's off the record it can be i don't
want to be on the burger show being like
i love
impossible burger but i do you guys
you got to support these guys all day
everyone's trying to hustle right now
we get to taste a very unique burger and
it's their special
let's eat this i'm ready we ready let's
do it i'm excited come on
watch my butt oh [ __ ] this is the gates
i always have trouble with
see it's always good to have a friend
hi my name is cecilia my name is alicia
and we are the owners and operators of
hangar birds in el sarino it's my wife
my wife
this is my mother-in-law's backyard
right now for the most part this is
where you'll find us
every two weeks the name kind of came
about we were thinking of names and what
a kid would say
miss spell it or miss saying they would
say hangover i mean that's how i used to
say it as a kid
before this we had zero food experience
yeah i'm a graphic designer i work for
disney when the pandemic started they
furloughed a bunch of us and i was one
of the ones furloughed it's kind of a
man's game
and there's not really women doing
burgers so that for me was intimidating
and i kept shelving that dream
and it wasn't until the pandemic that i
had no excuse
she took the chance she took the leap
and here we are
right now we make two styles of burgers
one is the original
the other is the the beak on our
original burger you're going to get
american cheese thin sliced onion and
our hangover sauce
and for our tepee you're going to have
grilled onions
american cheese hand slice vanilla
cheese
you will get tomato and the pig sauce
after
our trip to the peak nyadi we fell in
love with this burger
and so we thought let's try to make our
own version of it
i didn't expect this reaction to our
burger
the third pop-up the line was three hour
wait
and that just like all right we're in
this we've been together now for
almost 18 years almost eight years
married 18 years together
it's natural we just kind of complement
each other
okay yeah i know i can't talk get all
emotional
[Music]
this is the most put together pop-up the
branding is on punto
on point thank you how long have you
been doing this almost a year we're like
a month shy of a year
and they forgot merch you guys are ready
to like open like a real legit place
yeah you never know maybe that's next
maybe
we had burgers at our wedding yeah wow
wow that was our food
it's part of us so you're true to this
yes what are we thinking
well you gotta try the the beak gotta
try the original
i think we should start with the single
i just like that ratio
and then you can have more than one i'm
already a fan
ratio is super important it is someone
here
has had some type of restaurant yeah no
it's just because like
there's a boss on point like the ticket
rail blows my mind
like when did you even get your first
ticket probably like nobody should do
i used to roll up tape all these things
that you're saying
i believe them about you yeah take some
notes
i really am wow there's the smash that's
why one is just right
it's true i was gonna ask you if you
ever get bored of burgers but this is so
exciting
every burger is different now yeah and
then when the patty hits the grill it's
like a brand new party every time
seriously i came to party the candy lace
on that
is very important you know why this is
occurring because her griddle is so damn
clean
my mouth is watering i am just about to
lose my mind
it looks so good and here we go
i cannot wait i'm really excited about
all this stuff
so are we going original or yeah we're
gonna go original
okay whatever
oh my gosh wow first off it's crispy
perfectly seared the thinness of the
patty with the
amount of onions the thinness of the
pickles it's all well considered
yeah she's not lying and it hits bro
this hits
nine times out of ten a burger anywhere
in la new york san francisco sure
comes on a martin potato nine times out
of ten they taste exactly the same
because that's like their flex they're
like oh i'm on a martin's potato yeah
you're like
sorry bud like martin potato world's not
going to save you if your
burger is mint yeah if you're if your
burger's trash a martin potato roll does
not save you
if i was a burger pop-up and i was
serving a smash burger on martin's roll
i would change my bun i'm [ __ ] not
lying
in a male dominated wow burger pop-up
world
this is gonna have every dude shaking in
their boots yup
shaking in their bun also i'm just going
to start eating the tippy
it is so pretty
there's a lot going on how come this
hasn't come to light
before because this is just damn unreal
this is bangers
i feel like i'm eating a bodega
breakfast sandwich in new york
yeah at the same time as the so-called
that's what i was feeling burger show
approved wow where's your burger gavin i
don't have one
we need one you and i have connected
over many years
on like being filipino american socal
kind of like breaking some traditional
expectations
right we're not we're not working in the
health care industry
we're not we probably should be right
now what uh we chose
different paths we kind of both hit like
a [ __ ] point like
let me just follow my [ __ ] let's see
what we love and get it popping
and i feel like that's what this is
hangovers they just said [ __ ] it like
let's do it
i agree that's how you get new [ __ ] i
definitely think that this is going to
rock the burger world
real quick one word shook the future of
burgers is female
sam thanks for sharing burgers with me
you know i got nothing below for you
burger show we out baby
what's up burger world thank you for
watching make sure you hit that like
button
smash that subscribe button ring that
notification bell
if not for me for the burgers
i love you